there's only two ways you can get new
customers you can get it in a public
form you can get in a private form
private forms mean one-on-one dms
one-on-one cold calls one-on-one emails
it's basically a place where someone has
to do a password or an inbox to check
stuff what's important is getting a
personalized first line so all you have
to do is go to the person's profile look
at the most recent post and say hey i
like this thing something specific about
it and then you put the rest of your
offer and a key point of making the
response rate high if the easiest way to
get going is say that you work for free
and they can pay you after you deliver a
result it's the easiest way to get
people to say yes and then fill your
clients up and then if for some reason
they don't want to convert into clients
with you you can still ask for the
testimonial it also gives you the
opportunity to learn because you're
probably not that good right now because
you're trying to get more clients and so
it gives the opportunity to get better
and get testimonials so that when you do
have enough testimonials and enough
skill you'll be able to charge for